hello there today we're looking at what
matters in on policy reinforcement
learning a large-scale empirical study
by Google brain on high-level this paper
investigates a five different continuous
control tasks and they train agents with
all the different choices that you can
make basically on these continuous
control tasks so the different choices
are like network width and height of the
value and policy network learning rate
type of loss function regularization
constants and they train all of these
agents and they try to parse out what
works in general and what doesn't and
they have some surprising findings that
number seven will surprise you yeah okay
so that's the that's the study in higher
level as always if you like content like
this consider subscribing and sharing it
out that would be excellent so they say
the on policy reinforcement learning has
been successfully applied to many
different continuous control tasks while
our L algorithms are often conceptually
simple they're state-of-the-art
implementations take numerous low and
high level design decisions that
strongly affect the performance of the
resulting agents those choices are
usually not extensively discussed in the
literature leading to discrepancy
between published descriptions of
algorithms and their implementations so
the sort of things they mean here are
the things that when you read the paper
the algorithm will be sort of described
pretty well on the main idea but then if
you look at the code there's a whole
bunch of hacks there like on the Atari
environment you have to repeat certain
actions you have to introduce sticky
actions then the question is do you have
like a random starts or they always
start at the exact same time
therefore the randomness of the level is
not given then you whether or not you
normalize certain observations but we've
had these things even in supervised
learning or NLP things
like this we've had pre-processing I
remember the resonant first resonate
paper that beat imagenet to a
significant degree over the last year's
baseline it was oh yeah we have the
simple idea of the resonant and then
they have an entire section where they
go oh and we do this normalization we do
this pre-processing we do this and this
and this and this and this and I mean
there's an argument to be made for all
of these these choices but often it's
hard to disentangle who if the choice
choices of these pre-processing things
or whatever the choices are matters or
if the idea in the paper matters and
it's also very hard to compare different
things
so what they're doing here is I would
say this is not only a problem in RL
this is a problem generally they say as
a step towards filling the gap we
implement over 50 such choices in a
unified on policy RL framework allowing
us to investigate their impact in a
large scale empirical study so a large
scale empirical study is basically means
great search over these choices kind of
smart grid search we train over 250,000
agents in five continuous control
environments of different complexity and
provide insights and practical
recommendations for on policy training
of RL agents so as far as I could figure
out the code and/or end or the
checkpoints of these 250,000 agents or
the code of this unified on policy RL
framework is not available yet and I
don't know if it's going to be but
basically what they're doing is they're
building one agent so and usually you
have this agent environment dichotomy
right here you get observation and
reward and here you get you give action
they build one single agent that has a
lot of switches there's a lot of like
flags that you can say okay either do
you want this loss or this law school do
you want this regularization or this
regular a situation and if so by how
much right and so on so I have this
agent with lots and lots on
lots of switches over 50 of these
choices that they implement right here
and they can basically turn each one on
and off and therefore they can
investigate these algorithms so let's
jump over the most surprising finding
which okay the most I can tell you the
most surprising finding is that the
initialized the policy initialization
scheme matters significantly that's more
people maybe didn't know what also
matters a lot is the learning rate and
things like the discount factor but I
think people in RL were already familiar
with that I find it all so interesting
what doesn't matter namely most things
seem to not really matter too much but
there might be other explanations for
this all right so they say we consider
the setting of on policy reinforcement
learning for continuous control now this
is where I have a bit of a of a problem
right here because the title is what
matters in on policy reinforcement
learning it's not what matters in on
policy reinforcement learning for
continuous control they do say in the
abstract here as you've already seen in
the last sentence that they have
continuous control environment v
continuous control environments but yeah
I get it you need to make the title a
bit clickbait t but the title overstates
a bit what this paper says this paper
basically says what works in these
particular five continuous control
environments right so they vary a lot of
things with respect to the agent but
they keep the environments relatively
constant and it's not five diverse
environments it's five mu Joko
continuous control environments that are
very very very similar to each other in
terms of their observation in terms of
how the world works and so on so
consider this paper as an investigation
in what works and doesn't work for these
five and possibly for very relatively
closed environment
so that's that's I think my biggest
trouble I have with this paper right
here is sort of it over States what it
what it says in the title but I mean the
investigation itself is done I feel very
very well so they say they have a
unified on policy learning algorithm
where they research prior work took
popular code bases made a list of
commonly with Joyce's and then
implemented everything into starting
from the seed RL codebase seed RL is
kind of a framework for distributed or
for reinforcement learning in general
and they say whenever we faced we were
faced with implementation decisions that
required us to take decisions that could
not be clearly motivated or had
alternative solutions we further added
such decisions as additional choices so
this I feel if I write research code
this is generally what I do right I
write my research code and whenever I
come to a place where I'm like should
they use this or this should use this
optimizer or this optimizer I simply
make a flag and then even if it's just
one choice for now right just make a
flag and parameterize everything and
that's that's that's the thing here they
parameterize everything but other than I
would do now then I would sort of
sparsely explore the space of these
parameters now they do a more dense ops
dense observation or dense sampling of
this space then mmm it might me myself
would do with limited resources of
course being Google it is possible to do
these kinds of things where you
investigate all the choices so they say
here a difficulty of investigating
choices the primary goal of this paper
is to understand how the different
choices affect the final performance of
an agent and derive recommendations for
these choices there are two key reasons
why this is challenging first we are
mainly interested in insights on choices
for good hyper parameters yet if all
choices are sampled randomly the
performance is very bad and little
training progress is
so that means if you have if you have
all of these hyper parameters then let's
let's consider like a three dimensional
hyper parameter space then there are
combinations of hyper parameters that
are very good right here maybe here so
there's this this cube in here that's
sort of very good but the rest aren't
really good so if you just simply sample
from anywhere in the space like here or
here or here here here you we will
basically never get anything that works
you sort of have to hit the combination
correctly and that's that's a problem in
three dimensions but it's way more a
problem in 50-plus dimensions like they
have here so they have to resort to a
different strategy they have to go and
basically start out from a good
configurations where they say they group
these we create groups of choices around
somatic groups where we suspect
interactions between different choices
for example we group together all
choices related to neural network
architecture we also include the
learning rate in all of the groups as we
suspect it may interact with many other
choices then in each experiment we train
a large number of models where we
randomly sample the choices within the
corresponding group all other settings
for choices not in the group are set to
settings of a competitive base
configuration that is close to the
default PPO versus v2 configuration okay
so what they're doing basically is
they're saying now let's let's consider
these so these groups you can now think
of of single dimensions in this space so
or
yes so let's consider the space of
groups let's say you have two different
groups one is the group of network
architecture parameters and the other
one is a group of learning behavior like
learning rate and training algorithm
perhaps parameter what they're saying is
they're saying we know
of a configuration right here that is
good
this is PPO versus to see version two
and now what we're going to do is we're
simply going to keep in each experiment
we're going to if we want to investigate
the network architecture let's say
that's this axis we're going to keep all
the other groups the same as this
default configuration and only
investigate only basically move this
point to the left and to the right and
we're not going to move it up and down
we're going to keep the learning dynamic
parameters of the other group or all of
the other groups are going to keep the
same and only move it in in the
architecture parameter space now of
course this is not just one parameter
this since they make these groups this
is a Multi multi parameter so at each
point here you can imagine like a little
subspace of the inner group and they
then sample from these and that becomes
much more feasible right so now maybe
you have let's say you have ten groups
of five parameters each you can densely
sample five parameters like that's sort
of possible you cannot densely sample 50
but you can densely sample five so what
you would do is you would keep the other
45 constant that would correspond to
this dimension and all the other
dimensions and you would only vary
within the group which would correspond
to this dimension but now you see that
the problem again of course is that
you're always starting from this point
and you're basically only exploring
along the axes of this of this group
space because you always keep one
complete the others constant and that
basically to me that means that this
experiments are going to be heavily
favored in in terms of which of the
algorithms is closest to this to this
baseline because if so if I go with with
this particular algorithm I know that
these parameters are the best for this
particular algorithm where if I now use
any other algorithm these parameters
might not be
the best and my only my only way of
adjusting to that other algorithm is by
individually moving here while keeping
others counts so I can basically only
improve with it along one of the groups
I hope this makes sort of sense that it
feels like this experiment biases the
results in favor of whatever is made
whatever choices are made in this
baseline so keep that in mind now that
being said PPO of course is very popular
baseline so it makes total sense to use
that as a as a base to explore from but
it's not like they're doing an actual
dense grid sampling of the space they're
doing a sparse sampling in the group
space and then a dense sampling within
each group all right so they let's go
into the experiments the first thing
they investigate are the policy losses
now this is this is a rather important
topic and that basically means how do
you train the policy and the choices
here are of course PPO like we saw the
proximal policy optimization but there
are also others namely for example
policy gradient you might know that if
you learn about reinforcement learning
you will inevitably learn about policy
gradients like the first thing you learn
next to cue learning and then V trace is
another sort of policy loss V trace is
optimized for distributed reinforcement
learning and they have a bunch of others
and they here they say the goal of this
study is to better understand the
importance of the policy loss function
in the on policy setting considered in
this paper because not to provide a
general statement that one of the losses
is better than the others as some of
them were specifically designed for
other settings now I of course I agree
with this with this statement it's nice
that they repeated again right here so
all the results right here are just
valid for these environments or
environments
very similar to these and you have to
keep in mind that the baseline
parameters are PPO v2 and they only ever
vary one group from these baseline
parameters so that's why in this
experiment for example it doesn't seem
too surprising that the PPO loss as you
can see outperforms in every single
experiment here whereas the other losses
underperform so their recommendation is
use the PPO policy loss start with the
clipping threshold to 0.25 but also try
it lower and higher values if possible
because they have found and they have
Nevermore experiments and the appendix
the appendix is full of these
experiments and you can go and look at
them so they but the general
recommendation here for them is to use
the PPO policy loss if you have these
continuous control tasks and that there
is a strong influence of this clipping
threshold that is in PPO second thing
network architecture and that's
basically you have you always have a
value network in the policy network and
the question is how many layers how deep
and so on should you make them these
things here are just ml piece since this
is continuous control tasks you don't
learn from pixels as far as I understand
it you learn from the states or the
sensors on these robot simulated robots
now you got this here
they say separate value and policy
networks appear to lead to better
performance on four out of the five
environments and further regarding
network size is the optimal width of the
policy M of the policy network depends
on the complexity of the environment and
too low or too high values costs can
cause significant drop in performance
well for the value function there seems
to be no downside in using wider
networks moreover on some environments
it is beneficial to make the value
network wider than the policy
one agian half cheetah the best results
are achieved with 1632 units per layer
Daraa yadda-yadda-yadda
the so some there this is a thing that
sort of crystallizes out of this paper
because what you're doing is you have
these one policy network and one value
network like it states this um dichotomy
where the value network tries to
estimate the reward and the policy
network tries to maximize the value so
you have you have to learning things
here you have this is learned and this
is learn now there is a certain degree
of interaction as the value network of
course the reward is dependent on your
policy so the value network sort of has
to take into account the policy when it
estimates the reward but it seems to be
that the policy network is the brita ler
one and therefore more care has to be
taken to optimize it whereas the value
network seems to be a bit of more robust
to changes and we've seen this already
in that the the lost choice for the
policy seems to be quite important and
here also the network parameters for the
policy seem to be the things you have to
actually tune per environment whereas
for the value you can pretty much go you
can pretty much get any wide network
will kind of do okay so they say as for
activation functions we observe that tan
H activations perform best and really
perform worse which is interesting right
because you would think that in other
deep learning tasks Rea lose have become
pretty popular and usually outperform
these others other activation functions
but in this case no but this could also
be due to other things because again
they go from these default parameters
which for example do not have entropy
regularization built in and if you have
a real uu where it's basically an
unbounded function whereas the tan H is
sort of a more or more
that function so that could be you know
there could be significant interactions
here where they have split the groups
and then the choices might be reversed
if in the other groups these two
parameters were different but for now
apparently at ten H activations perform
best the interesting thing here is they
say interestingly the initial policy
appears to have a surprisingly high
impact on the training performance so
this is how you initialize the policy
Network again policy network appears to
be the more brittle one and the one that
you have to tune more the key recipe
appears to initial the key recipe
appears is to initialize the policy at
the beginning of training so that the
action distribution is centered around
zero regardless of the observation and
has a rather small standard deviation
this can be achieved by initializing the
policy MLP with smaller weights in the
last layer so if you have this policy
MLP as multiple layers and then it needs
to output an action distribution right
so in in these in these continuous
control tasks you basically for each of
the joints you have to affect so you
have like a little you have like a
little Walker here with four legs and
what's that that's like eight joints or
something so you have to tell this how
much force it needs to apply to each of
these joints and as I understand it
that's usually given by the network
outputting a mean and a standard
deviation I might be wrong here but
meaning the standard deviation for the
distribution of action that's going to
be apply here and then this is sampled
from that distribution the actual force
is then sampled now they say you should
initialize the network such that the
mean here is zero across or over your
observations and the way to do that is
to simply initialize this last layer
here
with very small weights so you and I
think their recommendation is to divide
to initialize this by 100 times smaller
weights than all the other layers they
say other choices appear to be less
important the scale of the last layer
initialization matters much less for the
value MLP again and for the policy MLP
apart from the last layer scaling
network initialization seems does not
matter too much
yada-yada-yada there appears to be no
benefits if the standard deviation of
the Polly's learned for each state or
once globally for all states for the
transformation of policy output in the
standard deviation soft awesome that
expenditure from similary so most of
these choices in their case appear to be
relatively similar except the ones that
they point out the recommendation here
is initialize the last policy layer with
100 times smaller weights use soft + to
transform network output into action
standard deviation and add a negative
offset to its input to decrease the
initial standard deviation of actions
tuned if this offset is possible use 10
H as both the activation function if the
networks are not too deep right here
this is probably where the rail lose
would start to shine and transform these
samples from the normal distribution to
the bounded action space sorry and to
transform by using at an H use a wide
value MLP no layers shared with the
policy but tune the policy width it
might need to be narrower than the
volume of P now this here this no layer
is shared with the policy this might
just this might be in our result that
the policy is quite quite brittle so if
you can detach the value and the policy
that might be of advantage which is also
surprising right you would think that
these two networks if they are should
have shared layers they would learn more
about the environment but apparently not
then normalization and clipping so you
get a bunch of normal
and clipping techniques which is for
example observation normalization
basically means that whatever comes in
you normalize it to a given range so
that's usually you do that for
supervised learning like if you have if
you have M missed digits so this is a
mostly black image with okay can I draw
on this with like a small portion of it
is white and what you want this is
usually in the range of 0 to 255 so you
have 0 to 255 what you want to do is you
want to normalize that such that it's in
the range negative 1 to 1 or
alternatively such that its mean is 0
and its standard deviation is about 1 so
people use both things and they tend
this alone tends to already boost the
performance so the fact that it's known
that this is non-negative and also the
fact that this number is somewhat higher
then sort of in the 0-1 range these are
quite important and they're gonna figure
out that this is also important right
here so the recommendation is always use
observation normalization and check if
value function normalization improves
performance so for value function
normalization I believe you would you
would normalize the output of the value
function so instead of the value
function telling you this is how much
worth something is it simply can tell
you sort of that it's more or less worth
than something else in a normalized
range gradient clipping might slightly
help but is of secondary importance okay
cool yeah so all the other things also
don't seem to matter too much like per
mini-batch advantage normalization and
gradient observation clipping yep then
advantage estimation so advantage
estimation in reinforcement learning is
it basically the
the value network needs to be trained
right so you take a step and a step and
step and a step and in each step you get
a reward and you get you perform many
steps now the value network sitting
right here needs to be trained to
predict the total rewards that you can
get from here on until the end of the
episode now usually what you do is you
can bootstrap this by sort of a temporal
difference thing in that you consider
the you you consider a few steps into
the future and then you ask your own
value network what it thinks of the rest
of the episode so basically you train
you don't train on the entire rest of
the episode you train on the difference
between this and this and then you can
get way more complicated where you
actually ask your value network at each
step what it thinks and then you go to
that value network while integrating
this reward but you also go to this
value network while integrating these
two rewards and so on and then your
target becomes sort of a mixture of all
of these things you can get super
complex with these with these different
variants and they say we compare the
most commonly used advantage estimators
and step ji-ae and V trace and they're
hyper parameters and their
recommendation is use the GA with lambda
equals 0.9 okay I feel this is not is is
not too too too surprising right here
because this this n step is a very basic
estimator and TGA and the V trace are
better and they say the GA and the V
trace they appear to perform better and
they have not found a significant
performance difference between the two
so cool
last thing no this is second second to
last thing almost last thing training
set up now I believe this this becomes
more important
so they investigate choices related to
data collection and mini-batch handling
so the number of parallel vironment s--
the number of transitions gathered in
each iteration the number of passes over
the data and so on so this is going to
to matter quite a bit the recommendation
is to go over experience multiple time
so what you do in these environments is
always you have a phase where you
collect experience and then you have a
phase where you learn from this
experience and so you collect experience
you start from here you collect a bunch
of experience you put all of that
experience into a buffer which is like a
database and then you have these what
they're called traces right so all of
these are now episodes that your agent
took now all of these episodes consists
of many many steps that the agent took
so here is one step here is one step
here is one step and each of these steps
are going to be one training sample so
each of these steps and also here and
here are going to be one training sample
there are multiple problems here the
first and obvious one is if they if you
just leave them in order then you will
have very very correlated mini-batches
and that's not good so you want to kind
of shuffle them around in here
each time before you go to them you can
go through them multiple times in
different order and that works really
well they say you should go over your
experience multiple times since that
doesn't hurt you and it alleviates you
from the necessity to collect more data
the second thing they say is you should
shuffle individual transitions before
assigning them too many batches okay
we've we've concluded that and you
should recompute advantages once per
data pass now what's the point the point
here before we talked about you have to
have these advantage estimators which
basically means you have to look for
each step you have to look ahead
a couple of steps decide what the value
of this state is or the advantage and in
order to do that as we have seen you
kind of look at your own estimation of
that future value so you have this value
is dependent on your own estimation of
the future value now of course if you
just do if you can only do this if you
have these episode traces if you have
these blue episode traces still around
you know which step comes after which
you cannot do this anymore once this is
all in mini-batches and shuffled so what
some people do is they simply compute
these things once at the beginning with
the value network they have and then
they go multiple times over this data
and just they shuffle them a shuffle
each time but they keep these estimates
and that's of course is more and more
out-of-date the more often you go over
the data so what they recommend is you
should always go back to this set data
set recompute these estimates with your
current value network then do the whole
shuffling thing again and then do
another epoch and then basically come
back to here again and come recompute
the advantages it it makes a lot of
sense right but they also find that this
actually makes a difference for faster
wall clock time training use many
parallel environments and increase the
batch size both might hurt the sample
complexity but they get you a faster
wall clock time which makes sense right
if you have more environments than
you're gonna collect more experience and
more different experience and that will
speed up your the time that you need for
learning you might collect more samples
though so it will also increase your
flops tune the number of transitions in
each iteration if possible okay so next
thing is time step handling what do they
do
the choice is related to the handling of
time steps so this is the discount
factor frame skip so in these
environments you can choose to like
ignore intermediate
frames how episode termination due to
time step limit are handled and their
main thing here is that the discount
factor is one of the most important
hyper parameters and should be tuned per
environment and start with a point nine
nine discount factor try frame skip if
possible there's no need to handle
environments step limits in a special
way for large step limits okay so the
discount factor which is also
unsurprising right because the discount
factor is basically how how much you
discount future reward and that is
inherently dependent on the reward
structure of the environment itself so
it's really unsurprising that this is a
big and important hyper parameter but
it's good to note and then last second
okay there's more second to last thing
optimizers they investigate different
optimizers we invest a two
gradient-based optimizers Adam and
rmsprop
as well as their hyper parameters and
their result says you should use Adam
with a momentum though I think they
found that rmsprop isn't too much behind
that but they say you should tune the
learning rate absolutely which is also
known in the community right you can't
you if you have a different problem it
might require a different learning rate
and they find the learning rate to be a
important parameter for an important
parameter for these problems so you
should tune it but the other parameters
of the of these algorithms aren't too
much of an influence at least on these
particular problems and then the last
thing is regularization
so in regularization they try different
regularizing methods such as entropy
regularization soft constraint and
trapeze should not be lower than some
threshold callback ly blur divergence
between reference distribution and so on
and they say we did not find evidence
that any of the investigated regular
risers helps significantly on our
environments with the exception of half
cheat on which all constraints help so
they don't find a particular thing but
remember this again this for example
here entropy regularization is used in
the Impala paper which is which in which
proposes V trace now they here only have
an experiment where they changed a loss
to V trace without entropy
regularization and in this case they
turn entropy regularization on with the
PPO loss as far as I understand the
paper and there you can already see that
there is a space that is not explored
that is the setting of the original
paper that introduced the thing and I
think this this if you can remember this
study this study like are all Gans
created equal they concluded that
probably all Gans are created equal
especially like washed angin isn't too
much better than anything else and the
author of the Voss search tagging paper
was furious because they didn't in they
clearly said in the Vassar Stein gain
paper that they Adam optimizer doesn't
work and they had to use rmsprop and
then the rmsprop was not in that study
included so it seems that the
limitations of being able to really
densely explore these choices is quite
it's quite hurtful in in that you can
only even though this is a super
large-scale study and they train so much
right you can only ever make very very
very limited very limited sort of
conclusions in these things and I would
say if you are in these types of
problems definitely consider their
default settings otherwise what I'd much
rather do is to just go to like a piece
of code that implements as close as an
environment as possible to the one I
want and take the hyper parameters from
there in the appendix here they describe
all of the things that they've tried
with the choices of hyper parameters and
all of the results and you zoom in on
like a random one you already see that
the
results often times are very diverse
very wonky very much like maybe you know
this thing isn't so relevant or there's
large performance differences that are
unclear between the environments so it
remains to remains to be seen but the
main interpretation here is that you're
probably going to have to tune hyper
parameters for a while on your own
environments all right
yeah the appendix is really long and if
you want details I invite you to look at
it and apart from that I'll see you next
time bye-bye